the second skill that I think is
incredibly important and this is maybe
the number one or number two skill I
think in terms of business I think it's
the number one skill and so this skill
is copywriting I think copywriting is
the most important skill that you can
have for business and one of the most
important skills that you can have in
life and here's why when you learn how
to write well you learn how to think
well you when you learn how to write
clearly you weren't learn how to think
clearly and copywriting is a particular
type of writing but it's not just
limited to writing copywriting is
understanding how people think and how
they feel and how to use the written
word or a script or spoken word in order
to sell a product or sell an idea
basically how to use words to get people
to do what you want them to do and the
way that you do that is you have to
understand what motivates them what
makes them think what makes them work
and so this can be applied to literally
anything I have made tens of millions of
dollars this way using copywriting but
I've also met my wife this way I learned
when I was when I was trying to meet her
she was that way out of my league and so
I used what I learned in copywriting to
like get her attention and make her or
at least try to make her interested in
me
copywriting copywriting is incredibly
effective I've used it to get customers
like as in people to buy stuff from us
or for the hustle to get advertisers
I've used it to get speakers to our
events I've used it to recruit people
I've used it to sell people on this
interesting idea I have copywriting is
incredibly important and it boils down
to a bunch of really simple principles
but the easiest one to remember for this
conversation is ADA a ID a tension
interest desire action for the majority
of your copywriting life which for most
of you it has nothing to do with getting
a job it's just a good skill set to have
in life attention interest desire action
is the frame
work that you need so when you write you
line it up with attention can I get your
attention interests can I tell you some
facts that get you interested and get
you to fall down the slippery slope
because once I get you to start reading
my work I can get you to keep buying
into what I'm saying and it's really
hard to get people to fall down that
slope but interest by it specifically
tell them very interesting facts and
features about the story that you just
started with your your action point or
sorry your a tension point desires the
second part so I'm gonna make you desire
whatever I'm selling and I'm gonna get
you to desire that by telling you things
that you don't know and how this can
benefit your life and then finally
action I'm gonna tell you specifically
how to get you to act and so here's an
example that my friend Neville always
uses uses that I love which is if I'm
gonna tell you I'm gonna try and
convince a 15 year old guy to drink more
water I could say drink more water it's
healthy for you or and a lot of these
facts aren't necessarily true because I
didn't research what water does for you
but I very easily could use this premise
for that I'm gonna say have you ever
seen those guys with huge muscles at the
gym carrying around gallons of water in
their hand it's like they use those milk
containers to carry water so that's how
I get your attention you see they're
doing that because if you drink if you
drink a gallon of water a day the
likelihood that your muscles will grow
by 30% more than how do not drink water
now the reason that happens and this is
the desire part the yeah this is the
desire part the reason that happens is
because water has these molecules in
them that helps oxygen travel through
your blood and oxygen is needed to build
up your muscles that's my desire part is
I'm trying to show you how to build up
your muscles and when that oxygen goes
to your muscles
they grow 30% faster so and this is the
action part if you want to build big
muscles and be healthier than before you
need to drink about a gallon of water a
day per hundred pounds of body weight
so that action part I specifically
explained how to do that now that was
just a silly example I don't none of
that shit's true but you get the point
this ADA it works wonderfully
and I always think that I always tell
people you got to learn copywriting and
there's a few great ways to learn it
[Music]